quand je dis qu'on me qualifier
d'extraterrestres jeu faisait pas
référence aux officiers de sécurité du
j'espère je faisais référence à un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
dans l'administration sont
administratives pur jus pour lequel j'ai
pas tout à fait le profil de l'emploi
quand j'explique qu'il pouvait y avoir
des tensions avec eux c'est parce que je
suis un peu dans l'esprit du président
c'est que quand on me demande de faire
quelque chose je le fais je vais un peu
jusqu'au bout et parfois vous attirer
des inimités de gens qui vous explique
que ça fait 40 ans qu'on fait comme ça
et qu'on vous a pas attendu pour changer
les choses
bah ça peut créer des tensions parfois
et quand vous faites pas partie du club
excusez moi de l'expression et ben on
vous le reproche on vous le fait sentir
en tout cas d'une manière différente
c'était là dessus que il y avait cette
affaire de j'avais dit qualifiés qui ont
qualifié d' extraterrestes pendant sur
les déplacements privés le port d'armes
il ya toujours eu toujours eu est le
seul responsable de la sécurité du
président de la république c'est le
général lavernhe et il ya toujours eu
des éléments du j'espère en permanence
avec le président de la république il
s'est jamais retrouvé seul n'y avait
qu'un société curité ni avec moi il ya
toujours eu un dispositif complet jamais
je veux juste y ait jamais eu de trou
dans la raquette de la sécurité du
président de la république a toujours eu
le dispositif même parfois quand il
était minimum il ya toujours eu la
sécurité autour du président de la
république officiel toujours eu les
forces de police ou de gendarmerie avec
lui est-ce que je portais mon arme comme
une assurance telle assurance pour moi
même le président la république je
rentre pas chez lui
je rentre chez moi après quand j'ai fini
je vais apporter pour moi même pour ma
sécurité personnelle encore une fois je
le répète